for the moment let's go down back into
the the sports wormhole if you will and
to talk a little bit of sports and his
personal situation is one of the best
running backs in the National Football
League and pleased to have back here on
the Rich Eisen show one of the many
Wisconsin Badgers who no doubt wanted to
call me up or should i I've got the JJ
want mug right here should I put the jig
this cup holds Rich Eisen steers
Wisconsin 35 Michigan 14 is what JJ Watt
sent me so anytime we've got somebody of
Melvin Gordon on the show with with
where he went to school back here on the
Rich Eisen show we put this mug out here
how are you Melvin I'm good I have my
this mug that JJ Watt gave me that I
have to put on the desk I guess any time
a Wisconsin Badger calls into the show
that this cup holds my tears so that's
what it says that's what it says how are
you doing Melvin what's going on in your
world trying to work out when I can just
really just sound about the way okay and
everybody in your world healthy happy
everybody good as far as you know or
knocking on there to hear that I met
yeah you know as you know I met your mom
it's like seems like a lifetime ago but
it was last summer when you were getting
set to to play and I know that you said
at the time man I I want to stay here in
Southern California and play for the
Chargers but I just don't know you know
what what what led you to your decision
that you I know you're talking a lot
about that lately and I appreciate you
calling in one more time looking back
right now you said you regretted that
decision can you put a little bit more
meat on that bone for me Melvin you know
what I want to do as a player on the
field and just kind of my mark and where
I want it to be and you know you know
looking down the road I think you know
but I'm looking at you know my
statistics and everything it's like man
you know about uh you know stories the
whole year out you know where where
would I be as a player you know now but
you know I can't take that bag but as
far as the contract itself still wasn't
anything on that so that's definitely
not the reason it's
or so you know you know my my marketing
click right and then no walk me through
your free agency period here in Melvin
you want to talk about unique times what
was your free agency tour in quotes I
guess like it was crazy man you know
just you know just and everybody go off
the board and just kind of you know just
talking to this team and talking to that
game and it was just crazy man you know
it's not really you know what it's
cracked up to be
you got a couple of things that's really
interested and you know it's a couple of
teams that you know just want to see
what they can get you for it
I don't mean it it's really frustrating
it's not as cool as its coolest first
you know as it is for fans for you know
it's really stressful I would say you
know for the players but you know it is
what it is but all it was it was
stressful I'm sorry to hear that so what
I guess what was it stressful love was
was part of the stress and the fact that
you couldn't visit anybody I guess and
face to face I mean what was it were you
talking to people zooming what was that
part of it like I mean you know it sucks
not being able to fly into the teams and
you know you know meeting people and
people seeing you firsthand and you know
I think that you know I you know and I
think that hurt maybe a couple players
maybe you know not actually being able
to go in and people get an exam and you
and look at you it you know feel for you
or bring you in a film see you know
really how I bright you are as a player
you know those you know that obviously
didn't help but just you know being in
my position my position group you know
as a running back you know being in the
market it's not it's not the easiest
it's not the easiest thing you know
we're just not the position that's like
right now in and um you know going to
the market you know as a fact open
market as a package just you know this
point in time right now timing is just
not it's just not good why Melvin
here on the Rich Eisen show I guess part
of that is maybe that it's not that your
position isn't liked it's just that your
position is liked it somebody coming out
of college not just because of youth but
because of financials and what I'll give
you the floor what does a player with a
few years at that position have that you
think benefits your position that maybe
some kid out of college isn't as
somebody who came off the campus at
Wisconsin is now maybe a little bit more
wisent throughout the years I mean this
you know you go out there it's
definitely feel more natural you know
Conner of position if you got it you got
it but you know it is a lot of smarts
that go into you know everything you
know knowing protections knowing you
know what to read it having really a
good feel the word of lines supposed to
be and how they flow and when you're
supposed to go back or knowing coverages
and knowing okay if they getting this
type of coverage you know I know if I
take it back side I got this corner 101
its predetermine things a lot early to
make you play a little faster and just
like little maxing things with
quarterbacks you know that depends on
you know who you're with foot it is it's
more than just going out there and
playing it's really a lot that goes into
it and obviously the protection is the
number one thing you know one of my
coaches told me you know if a player
can't learn protection within the you
know the first two years and he pretty
much don't have a chance so it's just a
lot of things that really go into the
position there rather than just getting
the ball and run it like I said it is a
natural position you know it's really
instinct but if you really want to take
your game to the next level it's really
a lot that kind of goes into it Melvin
Gordon here on the Rich Eisen show and
it's interesting I'm sure last year when
you were looking for a new contract from
from the Chargers you were pointing to
the
Zeke contract I'm sure once that was
final and also the Gurley contract that
now is null and void with him in Atlanta
for one years six million dollars what
advice would you give to Derrick Henry
right now Melvin I was hoping to go play
I believe you know that's ten million
he's making a lot more than I was
supposed to make out you know may make
five but he's making ten million and
Tennessee you know I really don't know
how to tackle this but I'm pretty sure
they're not you know as bad as Catholics
are right you know it's tough man cuz
they really they really use they wore
him out last year and you can only think
if they playing him the same way when
contract talk when I talked him up
they're gonna be like well he's worn out
it and then they'll use it against you
so I don't know it's tough um it's tough
man it's a tough position to be in
in all honesty man and like I said
before I really don't wish that
situation on any player but here we are
again you know and and I have no idea
you know I haven't talked to me I've no
idea what he's gonna do but I would just
I would just have to you know something
to just just weigh out his options you
know you know just think how much you
can bring in and and if you sit out how
much how much can it really hurt you
I think he's going into a market next
year that you know a lot of backs are
gonna get paid I think Christian
McCaffrey
a lot album Camaro all those guys are up
so you know you could play into that
factor if I do sit down wait those guys
will get paid so then I have you know
better numbers and and you know to go
off of it's a lot of a lot of factors
that he can you know that he has that I
didn't so I was another factor that he
has that you didn't Chris Brockman you
you want to inform him of the state
income tax law in Tennessee yeah
Tennessee has no state income tax there
you have it
several percent right there difference
between cats it's a large percentage and
then before we turn the page to Denver
and and why you chose them and how you
chose them in in the conversation in
your press conference into
teleconference you said that you ruined
relationships in in Los Angeles or with
the Chargers what what what are you
talking about when you said you ruined
relationships you thought with your
holdout things like that and I got that
maybe I did maybe I did but it just kind
of it felt that way I felt tension as I
you know i sat out you know it's you
know they said what they said I said
what I said
you know I've seen the big media frenzy
so it was definitely tension maybe more
so on my part you know I do overthink
things a lot and maybe I just felt that
way and you know I repeat the said I
respect the owner a handful because like
I said after the Tennessee game he came
out and you know I didn't tell him to
walk up to me no one's home to walk up
to me you know maybe he felt attention
and he just walked up to me and he just
let me know Mel and I'm happy that
you're back and that meant a lot to me
for the owner to come up you know to me
and say that and that's kind of when
things start you know smoothing out for
me so maybe it was just in my head you
know maybe it was just in my head but I
felt tension and I felt like maybe I
ruined you know relate some
relationships were holding out you know
so I said man is what it is but there
was some tension
I felt so you were referring to
management not in the locker room or was
there some in the locker room with your
team I mean maybe I mean it was no
tension with me in the fellas because I
stayed in touch with them throughout the
whole time I made sure that you know I
can't connect with you know I don't have
everybody upstairs number and you know
you know we're going through negotiation
so I didn't think it was proper really
to reach out to them and but my
teammates I have asked
and I talk to them you know throughout
the whole throughout the whole time
I made sure I stayed in contact with
them I stayed around maybe I flew up
there sometimes and I kicked it with
them you know and they had free time I
made sure I stayed close with them so
detention wouldn't be you know it's bad
with them I felt like that's why I
wanted to ask you so I was wondering if
the coaching staff made you feel that
way too when you returned a little
tension probably now within my coach
with in my position coach coastland I
think he you know he you know he was
good about everything you know if he did
have sense and I couldn't really tell um
but I could tell maybe for some other
coaches that they were probably little
hot about the situation um you know you
know I kind of felt like some coaches
didn't even speak to me anymore you know
I kind of felt like that or it was kind
of forced maybe but my position coach
was the head coach the position coach
they were they were they were they were
solid my position coach met I have a
great relationship with him and he was
just he just had been having back in the
room to help beat the guys and like I
said you know I didn't think coach Lynn
had any intention at all in if he did I
didn't know it but you know you could
definitely tell some tensions between
some other soldier and you know we
already in that room you and Austin
Eckler got along well I mean he just got
he just got paid by the team is that an
issue for you Melvin no you know since
he got in man he's been grounded and
I've been you know I've been I've been
helping him along the way and it's just
it's crazy to see how he came in I grown
as a player you know a lot of people
start out you know put us against each
other oh but you know he's a great
player man he deserves everything he has
coming for him I know his mom is happy
family just everyone man so I'm excited
for him and you know like I said he's
well desert Melvin Gordon here on the
Rich Eisen show look Melvin my phrase
that my mom always says and definitely
taught me is the phrase everything
happens for a reason that's that's what
I've always been
let you know brought up to believe and
now here you are I think you're in a
terrific spot I think you and Philip
Lindsay are gonna be a dynamite
combination
how have you been sold by the Broncos on
how this is going to work once the
football is snapped
Melvin know exactly how you know we're
going to be used I do know they're a
great organization you know and and you
know they have some great great players
around watch them you know got got a
nice a lot nice system even though I
think they're changing up some things
you can do offensive coordinator but as
far as you know how they're gonna use us
I have no idea I had no idea but
hopefully we'd be the best one-two punch
that we could be I'm going in I'm just
do what I can do and they took the fall
of my hands and make placement as far as
how we're gonna run things do things I
don't know I would have a good sense of
that you know we got to go to OTAs and
things like that right you know with
that being pushed back you know and
probably not even you know with the talk
not even athlete so okay so if that is
still a question mark freedom what why
did you choose Denver what what
attracted you to the to the Broncos you
know I played against them twice a year
I've only heard you know great things
about great things about them you know
great owner really close LaVon and like
I said you know I've watched them up
close I've seen Lindsay of close I'm
saying how they block for him you know
up close and and and they they open up
hose man obviously I'm not the best with
change you know I like to I'm really not
um I like going somewhere you know where
I'm comfortable and I kind of know you
know what's going on and obviously you
know that you know like I said I go up
against him twice a year so that's the
most comfortable spot for me and like I
said I like the system and I feel like
you know it was that line they're young
but you know for like that line I can I
can make something happen
what about the
fact that they take on the charges twice
a year did that appeal to you well I
played twice a year you know was it I
wanted I sat down a little I told you I
you know I get to play charge money like
that wasn't you know one of the bigger
factory but I knew hey if I go to Denver
you know I do get to play the charges
twice a year see my brother's twice a
year so that dope I say there's no
there's no I feel no type of way source
of charges man I understand that it's a
business I feel no type of way towards
my brother that's their great
relationship with all those guys in the
locker Hall but it is gonna be the
cleanest I hear no hey Melvin thanks for
the call appreciate it it's been too
long let's stay in touch Congrats on
that deal with Denver like I said I
think you and Phillip together are gonna
be a heck of a one-two punch and I can't
wait to watch it go and you deserve all
the success that you want Melvin right
back at you thank you let's so let's
stay in touch stay healthy that's Melvin
Gordon Denver Broncos running back